we started by getting a quadratic and I
asked you to graph y equals f of X what
I want us to figure out now this is the
first thing secondly we know what
happens will you as you values right
remember how are your previous lesson we
said if you take the absolute value of
this see these positive parts they'll
just stay where they are
but what happens this negative part this
little bottom of the curve yeah yeah
this is gonna like flip upwards yeah so
instead of this being down at oh I
should have we should have marked this
inch anyway this is at negative 2 and
1/2 and negative 1/4 right so there's
the vertex instead of being at negative
1/4
it's gonna be at positive 1/4 it kind of
like flips up like this right so that's
one of the transformations you can do
just slap your absolute value sides on
it we're gonna do one that's slightly
different we're going to use the algebra
to help us okay so if if I have the
absolute value which I'm not that was
last lesson but this negative part down
here would kind of look like a little
bump going upwards did that really bail
yeah you know how it like sort of
bounces so that was just like what we
saw before now what I want us to graph
is this guy it's similar but different
okay now you might remember seeing
things like this where we were looking
at odd and even functions do you
remember that we would put in negative x
with substituted negative X everywhere
we saw X and we would see what happened
right what I want us to do is to put in
negative x every see X and then draw
this new graph it's going to look
different to this okay I want you to put
in y equals and now replace all your X's
with negative X's we get a new equation
go ahead factorize that just like you
did before find the vertex and the
intercepts have a go it often is but
doesn't have to be right so you know at
the moment like you've been drawing
Cartesian planes for years now and we
always call this guy X we're always kind
of call this guy Y but it doesn't have
to be an X it could be a it feels yeah
same equation here right so maybe I'll
start you off by making sure your actual
expression you get again oh this is
correct if I put in a negative X
everywhere I saw X I'm going to write
this
do you see what I've done it's just a
straight swap for everywhere else throw
an X like here and here I'm gonna put in
a minus X now I want you to take that
expand that out and treat it just like
you did before you're gonna try and
factorize that use that to find the
intercepts use that to find your vertex
okay off you go
see how far you can get okay
now I didn't give you as much time to
have a look at that one as I did the
first one but that's because you might
be starting to sense some real
similarities very good start we'll come
to that point in a second let's just do
the let's do the work to get there cuz
not everyone's at the sales point right
just have a look quickly first at our
substitution right so I swapped our X's
for negative X's this is what I got when
I expanded out my brackets and then just
like before my first instinct is to
factorize right what's the factorization
for this guy X minus 2 and X minus 3
right which you might think Oh hold on
this looks familiar doesn't it but
there's a subtle difference okay instead
of my roots being at negative 2 and
negative 3 my roots are at yeah just 2 &
3 there on the positive side right so
just like before I'm gonna go 1 2 3 now
then I think okay I've got an intercept
here and intercept here by the way as
I've been walking around and I'm sure
mrs. Leedy noticed this as well please
watch out for the consistency of your
scale a whole lot of you your distance
between 2 & 3 might be the same as your
distance between 0 & 2 which it
shouldn't be because those distances
aren't different right so please watch
out for that I've got 2 and I've got 3
the next thing I did was my y intercept
can you tell me the y intercept it's
still 6
huh that's funny and then you go ahead
you find your vertex and what you may
have found should have looked very
suspiciously familiar right what did you
get is the coordinate to the visit same
is the other one with one difference
yeah the x value well the x value over
here is between the in deserts and your
x value over here is between the
intercepts but they're somewhere else
right so you're getting this guy down
here the Y value is still negative 1/4
just like before right so what
you've got ears I'm gonna do my very
best there we go
happy times okay now just one quick note
before I leave off discussing this I
should put some values here and here it
here you can see one of the things that
I always watch out for is the overall
shape of the parabola now excuse me one
of the common errors that I'm seeing
some people do don't draw this please is
that when your parabola kind of goes
toward the edge right you sort of like
oh no I'm running out of space on my
graph and it kind of like does this
that's really big no-no well you've got
all these other great features on the
graph that you've done accurately but
this is not the shape of a parabola
right it never kind of levels off like
that it keeps on getting steeper and
steeper forever if you cannot fit onto
your graph to do that don't draw the
rest of the graph right just actually
take off part of it so it doesn't do the
wrong thing better to do nothing than
the wrong thing this is what it's
supposed to do
same deal over here are you okay with
the shape there yeah I could probably
clean this up a little bit if I had done
this on paper I would have done it in
pencil first then I'd go over in pen
what I'm happy with the shape okay now
this is the point of this right and
we're starting to come to where we can
actually write the heading what is the
relationship between this graph over
here this is y equals F of negative x
this guy is the graph of y equals f of X
right what's the relationship between
these two certain kind of called out
right at the beginning but I want to
articulate it more carefully for all of
us right what have we done to turn that
graph if you just ignore the algebra
five wiped off all the algebra here and
you had to give someone an instruction
to turn graph number one into graph
number two what would you tell him
suppose there was no algebra right if
we're just looking at the pictures there
sure what do you think you have a look
at the shape right some of you actually
thankee hold your can I borrow your book
actually now I didn't I didn't give you
any specific instructions on this I'm
just gonna delicately hide this graph
because it's not what you want to show
us right parented a big enough graph
that he could fit both of them on the
same set of axes which is kind of
convenient until you do this but you can
actually see the
relationship really clearly here can't
you here's the original this is the one
you did right you're like Oh same y
descent right there okay
your x-intercepts have gone from
negative 2 negative 3 to positive 2 and
3 right same y-coordinate for the vertex
as well it's the same shape but as I
just said instead it exactly right
there's a reflection across the across
what the y-axis can we thank you can we
write that down write F of negative x
right let's write this down I think we
can fit it in underneath okay
F of negative x or y equals sorry I
should say y equals F of negative x is a
reflection across across which line
across the across the y-axis so
vertically right across the y-axis of
whatever we started with which is y
equals f of X okay you can see that we
crunch through the algebra found all the
same features but now that you know this
fact right if you know what f of X looks
like you don't even need to know what
the equation is if they ask you can you
now graph F of negative x well you're
gonna use you're gonna grab that right
and you're going to flip it over to the
other side